et la sixième semaine de l'industrie se
poursuit aujourd'hui la chambre de
commerce et de l'industrie de versailles
organisé une table ronde sur la
transformation des usines et des
entreprises
au programme de cette matinée une séance
de questions réponses avec les sociétés
yvelinoise dont les responsables ou de
psa poissy et de l'école d'ingénieurs
estaca l'événement attiré des demandeurs
d'emploi en phase de reconversion et
surtout des étudiants ils étaient une
quarantaine à avoir assisté à la
conférence on écoute j'accomplis n'est
élu à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie guettait au micro des mythes
et les vidéos
je peux vous dire que ça nous fait
grandement plaisir puisque hélas quand
on parle de l'automobile s'est souvent
d'une manière négative en termes de
licenciements et autres et la voir des
jeunes qui se destinent et qui sont
intéressés par la filière industrielle
et ses nouvelles technologies notamment
dans le cadre de lézinnes du futur je
peux vous dire que oui nos chambres de
commerce ça nous fait grandement plaisir